fire fire fire fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh so we'll have just talking about
something trivial and then I'll work
away from the camera and introduce you
and then we'll go back so you've been
having a good time in Prague yes
yeah it's pretty amazing employees I'm
talking with mo Maxfield who is
interested in the integration of
Aboriginal medical techniques into the
traditional system of Western medicine
and you're also well known as an eaching
drummer is that Romani journey in
addition managers or people worse so
that's the connecting point between the
drumming and the traditional Aboriginal
medical working with terminally ill to
find their own
managing some that's one of the facets
of it describe how this would look to
the outside day I mean do you drum with
dying people for dying people there's a
foundation in Argentina and many of the
people there are terminally ill they
can't go any further in the medical
system there and so they it's sort of a
holistic place that was developed down
there and when I go there with my
drummers I first requested to work with
no more than 50 people but a hundred and
twenty showed up so 120 is what I did
and I took six drummers with big Indian
skin drums and they will lie down in the
traditional journey posture and they are
very naive there are no drums and they
haven't heard them so about all these
nine subjects and they'll go on a
journey in the morning
afternoon and what happens is that their
brainwave patterns will change I did my
dissertation on that so you mean using
the Sonic the drum as a sonic driver yes
you're pushing groups of people into
Walters state into an altered state of
consciousness depending upon how easily
they will induct and how open they are
course you can stop at you know you can
stay in a Veda uh-huh you could stay
here or you can go so is it pretty well
established by studies that these brain
transitions are taking place under my
study is the only one that I know of
oh you mentioned you did your thesis yes
interesting why why does this happen I
mean why is the brain susceptible to
this kind of sonic driving it's acting
as the brain seems to come into a
resonance as that as the sonic goes into
the body on the different brain waves
through the ear it overrides some of
these in the pain input and it comes
into resonance like a tuning fork if you
let go into it into alpha high off or R
into theta and that's where all the
imaging occurs of course can a person do
this with their voice or is sugar out
it's what the drum is one way uh-huh
psychedelics are one way chanting the
Bell is one way the gone but for
instance with the drum it isn't a matter
of oxygenating the brain in the way it
is with singing it's a pure case of
having it be sonically induce yes this
is interesting to me I've spent time in
South America
with people who take a psychedelic
called ayahuasca
and there are no drums to speak of in
the Amazon because the humidity no drum
head would remain stretch they only do
cutouts into logs yes
but they can see Saturday Don ayahuasca
yes it's and I wonder about the
neurophysiology of sound it seems to be
a relatively ignored area in Western
medicine yes I agree
what talk a little if you can about your
notion of the potential that sound might
have in some future medicine I think
that it was probably a very integral
part of all medicines and I believe we
lost it I know little about anything but
the drama
clinically or medically and I'm not that
heavy a clinician and function only with
brainwaves because my experience with
just drones was so profound I said
something's happening here and then when
I was in a study for the University of
California with an alpha training where
I was taught to go into alpha theta
States I noticed that I would be able to
track the state through brainwaves
you've got to be able to track altered
states with brainwaves you just have to
that's the way that works so let's prove
this and so when I every researchers
dreaming is when you find a whole new
literature there that was sure
absolutely and I need I need my studies
validated I need other studies to do it
but what I envisioned for this is you
can take people who normally would be
much too fragile or frightening or
traditional to use another doorway
whatever that doorway may be and with
normal looking people playing some
exquisite drums that have good tones and
say this is an ancient technique for you
know finding your own psychopathology
it's safe we'll keep you in fifteen to
twenty minutes and you have to do that
research my research prove that you have
got rats that when you do that and then
you come back and then you're back and
it's safe and you can tell somebody
you're not
you don't have to be frightened why do
you or how do you connect it to the
eating what about it is eating related
well as I was walking around one day
between classes with Angela's eyes and
we were working with the eating very
deeply as said a voice said I wonder if
one would be able to try to eat you so I
talked to Angie and we immediately
started working on it and if you draw
them you can cast him you can draw them
and it turns out it's a focus meditation
so for instance you have 64 hexagram
he's in the King Llane sequence and here
we have a drone yes now to help now what
do I do
all right let's take let's start if I
were going to teach you to drum I'd
start you with the trigram let's take
fire okay I'll start from the bottom the
way it's cast and it's so simple because
it would be fine
fire the long beat is dia is the solidus
sing-along is it is the two half ones
and you drum all the way up
I see so you view the lot in length
that's indicative of an interval yeah
interesting and then how do you set
other values like key and tone well of
course with a drum this is not that I
sing anyone took it and did it with an
ocarina it was just great I don't know
other musicians will do this so can you
sit down and play the King wind sequence
in 384 beats one seat for each la yes
yes so you know so like if I take every
position of fire that can be fire above
the mountain fire below the mountain
fire but then there's a sheet of music
for fire so it's like almost like box
method of composition
theme and variation recursion inversion
mirror image exactly stuff and there's a
there's a wonderful thing that we
journey people with that's all of the
yin trigrams put together four times for
the four full way against all the Yang's
are exactly opposite so it's called the
polarity duet uh-huh so you'll have you
know three drums playing one three drums
pulling another you can't go as far on
it keeps you in the channel and all
kinds of relationship issues come up on
your journey and is it actually musical
or is it just quirky and peculiar it's
fabulously
and you will be able to hear the
different resonances of the different
patterns they're very very different if
I play all the game it's very different
from your receptive and immune it's very
different you can feel it it seems that
this I mean this is probably sacrilege
from your point of view but it seems
like this set of ideas would lend
themselves very naturally to computer
composition absolutely oh I see nothing
nothing sacrilege is this you know what
I'm doing a sacrilege huh
Annie team sky I would probably have a
stroke possibly surprise you yeah got a
pick him carefully yes well that's very
exciting where do you see it leaving or
what would you like to do with that
we're working with people in groups of
people one things that happen is that
everybody wants to play a musical
instrument and most people have a secret
desire to drum spin jerk from our
culture through the Christian Church
this that is why sensuous and you can't
do that anymore so people are finding
the can drum they get hands on it's a
kinesthetic entry into one of the oldest
books on the planet into an ancient if a
blending at least in West and you cannot
do the drumming if you're not grounded
in your body you cannot do it and it
takes practice because as you begin to
drum the sequence you stay here and you
also go out and you can feel yourself
starting to leave and yet if you believe
since it's a random pattern because your
drumming hexagrams you lose it you lose
your place so you have to train to stay
present and to go which is exactly what
the shamanic practices either
is this method and mnemonic device as
well in in other words can you tell me
then how to construct hexagram 54
because you just think so so it isn't
you have internalized the structure of
all 64 hexagrams yeah but I'm sure that
what this will come as you develop I'm
sure I'm sure because the the languages
that they used to speak the the drum
languages in Africa I mean they had to
learn much more than this but we're just
I'm not accustomed to do that so it's
pretty new it's well then there are so
many ways that these hexagrams could be
arranged math met ones that derive from
mathematical forms of order yes random
throws the king wins you can sit down
and drum I'm writing music for each
individual hexagram that rose through
the nuclear trigrams so that you honor
each energy that in the drum it over and
over and over again if you can hold it
uh-huh but you spaced out and you lose
it that's how you know how well your
training as a drummer is how long you
can hold one of these patterns without
leaving your body
so have you discussed in any of this
with Mickey Hart
he had my dissertation but I didn't get
the research that long enough so I don't
know whether it finally got to her oh it
probably did he has a lot on his plate
because he cares more for drumming than
anything else on there is no and I'm
close to that yeah he lives up man yeah
well this is very interesting how do you
see it working back into the whole
larger theme of this conference and the
global crisis it sounds like as I was
talking to Angie we came upon this
notion of the archaic revival yes is
that there are many many impulses in
society from house music to what you're
doing to what Robert Bly is doing do
well that are often appear at cross
purposes but resolve themselves down
into impulses toward the recovery of the
archaic and the Aboriginal yes you know
everything from psychoanalysis to
National Socialism to psychedelic drug
so forth so this would be part of that
well I want I can tell you a very short
story when I first started teaching they
wouldn't one group that loved the
struming the most are adolescents
teenagers and children there right away
for you oh I can teach a full year old
faster than the father of the
four-year-old because they're so natural
and she said to me she was having a
fight with a girl across the way but
they were drumming together on the
polarity duet and she said you know you
just can't stay mad at somebody that you
what do you think of house music gives a
phenomenal singer it's this beyond rock
and roll club music that's becoming more
and more popular in England in Germany
and it's very percussive AHA and it's
built around 123 beats per minute which
is become that's the new can and
basically I mean that's what they are
aiming for we see where that's gone so
you weren't aware of it in the back of
my mind yeah I can see the rap coming
out of trees they're coming rhythm what
them into percussion and then as the
story talks about going back to the drum
and I'm sitting in the audience and I
say oh I know what you're doing
let me just ride that beatin going out I
mean you can be dominate here Matthew
deep wisdom as mom's right so it's a
return to trance to story tell them to
do it to shamanism
well thanks for stopping by yes I'd love
to teach you to drive I'd love to have
you teach me - damn we live close enough
together maybe we can get in touch
sometime I'd like that I'll bring in my
daughter okay well I'll see that you get
this software because I said you may
have ideas for how to make music nearly
every time I show it to someone with any
background in music they say there's a
way to turn this into sound let's
collaborate I'll get it - good luck
enjoy Europe okay fine fine
fire
fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you - thank you for the
opportunity